so what are we going to be talking about
today is whether or not numbers exist
and we're gonna be thinking about three
different schools of thought on this
first one's platonism second one's
nominalism and the last one is fictional
ism
so mathematical Platonism takes its lead
from Plato obviously as the name
suggests and the idea is that numbers
exist they really are things they're
objects but they're abstract objects so
they don't exist in the same way that
tables and chairs do in space and in
time numbers exist outside space outside
time they don't cause other things to
happen
they're totally abstract objects one of
the reasons that people like
mathematical Platonism is that we think
that a lot of claims about about numbers
and mathematics are true right so
certainly I think that things that
mathematicians say are true I think
that's a good starting point but they
say things like there's a number between
six and eight that seems like it's a
true thing it's in the number seven and
play to this think that that means it
must exist an object that is the number
seven even if it's not an object that
you can touch and they appeal to kind of
similar reasoning about the way that we
speak about the ordinary kind of
concrete world so if I say to you that
there's a nose between two eyes that
knows have better exists for what I say
to be true right if there's no nose here
then what I've said is false so in the
same kind of way right if there's a
number between six and eight that thing
had better exist playtest
aren't happy to use a loose sense of
exists here so they think that exists
just means exists in the so in the same
way that a table exists a chair exists a
number exists all the numbers exist in
fact it just so happens that they're not
located in space and time so it's a
difference about location rather than
whether or not they exist or whether
they exist in a different kind of way
all sorts of fun problems with the view
the first of which that you come across
particularly when you start teaching
this stuff is that's crazy right so
numbers exist outside space and time but
what does that even mean right it's
really really hard to kind of get your
head around but we can be a bit more
refined than that when we're objecting
to mathematical Platonism so one of the
things that we said was that
mathematical claims are true but their
mathematical claims are actually claims
about these abstract objects these
abstract object don't causally interact
with us because
abstract okay but we think that
mathematicians are massively reliable
right so so what they say pretty much
guaranteed to be true if their claims
are actually about these abstract
objects then then it looks like we need
some explanation of how those
mathematicians so reliably track that
world of abstract objects so if
mathematician tells you that you know 6
times 7 is 42 then then you know what
he's saying is true what this thing's
true how is it that they're so reliably
managing to access this world of
abstract objects answering that question
is really hard for the platanus because
they just don't think we can interact
with that world
a second theory is mathematical
nominalism so what the nominalist wants
to do is agree with the platanus that
all of our mathematical claims are true
but that our mathematical claims should
best be understood as claims about
objects in the world
so tables chairs pencils those kinds of
things and to get a kind of a bit of an
intuition or on this kind of thing often
helps to think about the way you might
teach a child to count so children don't
tend to be born with this kind of
abstract principles one two three four
five six and so on and what we tend to
do is to say like oh here's a pencil
here's another now you've got two
pencils and and it seems that what we do
when we learn to count is we count with
respect to a particular type of object
or auto objects in general and what the
nominal list says is well that's all
there is to number talk right what what
do you mean when you say 6 times 7 is 42
is that if you had 6 lots of 7 objects
you'd have 42 objects that that's what
mathematics is about it's about concrete
things in the world this kind of
nominalist view begins to run into
trouble when we start to think about
more complicated numbers or numerical
concepts so if we start to think about
the square root of minus 1 for instance
and the imaginary numbers and so on so
it's really easy to say 2 plus 2 equals
4 is about these two objects and those 2
objects and there being four objects
much harder to see what object or thing
might be the square root of minus
one so if your mathematical Platonism
other number just like all the rest but
but if you're a nominalist what's the
thing that it's about looks really
really hard to see what that's going to
be so so pi is is also similarly complex
right so if you're a nominalist it looks
like you're gonna think that numbers are
just numbers or keys just talk about
concrete things but of course pi doesn't
seem to have a precise value or at least
we certainly can't calculate that value
so there's a real question for the
nominalist here how are you going to
understand pi as a thing or a collection
of things when we can't ever get to that
contaminating value
our third group in the philosophy of
mathematics is is the mathematical
fictionalist so I said at the start that
I think it's a good thing to say that
what mathematicians say is true and the
fiction list doesn't quite agree so to
the fiction list says actually
mathematical discourse is false it's
really useful really helpful but it's
systematically just false
that's quite an extreme view to take
given the success of science within
which mathematics is embedded but that's
the view that the mathematical
fictionalist takes so the fiction list
says numbers don't exist so whereas the
plate inist says numbers are these
existing abstract objects and the
nominalist says mathematical discourse
is about concrete objects in the world
the fiction list says it's not about
anything it's just a useful story that
we've we've developed to help ourselves
get on in the world but surely the
mathematical fictionalist uses modern
communications is dependent on
satellites how do they explain those
things heavily because obviously they
use numbers how do they explain that
they're using something that they say
doesn't exist so what the fiction is has
got to do is is try and explain away the
success of mathematics and the success
of science but without saying that
mathematical claims are true and what
they are one strategy that the fiction
list can deploy around here is to say
that success in the world isn't a
hallmark of truth or needn't be a
hallmark of truth we were talking about
in modern communications technology
relying on all this mathematics what the
fiction list will say is what that
indicates is that the mathematics is
successful it doesn't indicate that it's
true if it was true says the fiction
list these mathematical objects these
platonic objects that the mathematical
play tennis thinks exist those things
would have to exist but they don't and
so in fact mathematical discourse can't
be true it cannot best be a useful
fiction I mean there's there's there are
appeals that they can make around here
that
that help bring out that the sort of
thing that they that they might want to
do
imagine that you thought that the Bible
was a work of fiction for instance some
people do some people don't but you
might think it codifies a really useful
set of moral principles and you might
think that there's no such thing wrapped
as truth in morality but you might think
as guiding principles go these are
pretty helpful they help us get on in
the world
don't kill other people help societies
develop which helps us develop an
interesting kinds of ways the
mathematical fictionalist might say very
similar things about the language of
mathematics helps us get on but that it
helps us to get on doesn't mean that
it's true where do you stand on all this
you've very neutrally given me the three
three positions do you is there one that
resonates with you so the view that
resonates with me the most I guess is
mathematical nominalism and so I don't
think that there are abstract objects I
don't think that there are numbers I
think that it's too much of a stretch to
think that mathematics is false my
colleagues in the math department will
I'm sure be delighted by this so so I I
adopt the middle ground what I take
through the middle ground anyway which
is a kind of mathematical nominalism you
were telling me that the nominalist runs
into problems with some of these more
spectacular irrational numbers do you
run into problems with those yes that
means that I inherit all of the problems
that the mathematical nominalist face is
the kind of move that I like to make
around here with respect to PI is to say
that whenever we actually calculate with
it when we're using it mechanically if
you like what we're doing is we're using
a best approximation now that's a that's
a spectacularly accurate or what well
it's a spectacularly long approximation
anyway I really shouldn't say it's
accurate because I think it maps to a
Platonic ideal but it's a spectacularly
long and very useful approximation but I
don't think there's anything other than
that endless sequence I guess and of
course you can derive that perfectly
except to me I think the reason that
philosophers get into the philosophy of
mathematics one of the reasons anyway is
precisely because there are so many
things to philosophize about it's
another thing for us to get excited
about
interested in the grand tradition of
doing or thinking about numbers that
goes right back to play so hence the
mathematical Platonism and so people
just get excited and interested in I
think